منذ بدء الحرب كان همهم الاهم هو مناقشه
ما سيفعلون في اليوم التالي
لانتهائها وقد ظنوا انا اذ بانهم لن
يحتاجوا الا اياما او اسابيع قليله لينجز
اهدافها المعلنه وفي مقدمها القضاء على
حركه حماس واسترداد اسراهم الذين يسمونهم
الرهائن فضلا عما لا يقولونه صراحه في شان
ترميم اسطوره جيشهم التي تهاوت بعد ثمانيه
وود من ادمانه الانتصار على جيوش كبرى
وجراره في بضعه ايام او بضع
ساعات لكن حصاد بيدر الحرب الجديده التي
صارت تعتبر مثالا استثنائيا على الوحشيه
المفلته من كل عقال انساني او قانوني خيب
رهانات من وضعوا حسابات حقلها في غرف
العمليات الحربيه واذ مرت شهور ثلاثه
تقريبا ابيد خلالها عشرات الالوف من
المدنيين الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه ودمرت
ديارهم وشردوا جميعا بلا رحمه فان صوره
الانتصار التي اشتهاها القاده السياسيون
والعسكريون الاسرائيليون والغربيون ظلت
ولا تزال عصيه على المنال بفعل مقاومه
استثنائيه شرسه فاقت توقعات اعداء فلسطين
ومحبيها على حد
سواء هكذا تاخر اليوم التالي كثيرا عن
موعده المرتجى اسرائيليا وامريكيه واوروبي
في حين اتضح مع كل دقيقه مرت على اندلاع
الحرب حمق اعتقاد من اعتقدوا بانهم
سيجلسون قريبا الى طاوله يتصدرها بنيامين
نتنياهو ليرسموا في يوم او بعض يوم خطه
الوصايه على الشعب الفلسطيني فينصب من
يحكمه ويفرض طريقه عيشه ويجبروه حتى على
تلقين اطفاله حب اعدائه ال الذين يستعمر
وطنه ويري قون
دمه لم تكن هذه بالطبع تجربه الاسرائيليين
الاولى في هذا الصدد غير انها تعتبر الاشد
فتكا بالمدنيين الابرياء في مسلسل حروب
يشنون منذ 6 سنه وطالما ظلت تقوم على اساس
الافتراض المتكرر من غير حكمه بان القضاء
على القوى الفلسطينيه المسلحه سينهي
القضيه الفلسطينيه كما سيحول الشعب
الفلسطيني الى امه داجنه احنا صامتين في
ارضنا ل يوم الدين بالمثل ايضا ليست هذه
هي المره الاولى وان تكن الاشد الما في
سفر صمود الفلسطينيين على ارض وطنهم
وتمسكهم بحقهم في الحريه والاستقلال ايا
كان الثمن الذي يدفعونه على مذبح الخلل
الهائل في ميزان القوى وبرغم توزع المواقف
الاقليميه والدوليه غالبا بين مفردات
التامر والتواطؤ والتخاذل لا بدهم ايانا
نتعلم ولا بدهم ايانا نصلي ولا بدهم
لاطفالنا اي حياه انهم يقدمون للبشريه
الان صوره اخرى حقيقيه سوى تلك الزائفه
التي سعت اله الدعايه الغربيه لترويجها
عنهم وهي صوره تتلخص في انهم ضحايا
مظلومون يتحدون قاتليهم فيده شون العالم
ويوقظون ضميره الغائب بل يدفعون ملايين
الناس في شمال الكره الارضيه كما في جنوب
بها الى ان يكتشفوا وهم على عتبه الاحتفال
بقدوم السنه العه بعد ال 2000 لميلاد
السيد المسيح عليه السلام ان اهل موطنه ما
زالوا على درب الالام يصلبون بالمئات كل
يوم وان قيم الحضاره الغربيه قد اصيبت
بجروح بليغه في مواضع عده من جسدها فضلا
عن اصابه روحها اصلا وفق تشخيص مفكرين
ومحللين سياسيين بفصام ما فاده ان ورثه
الانظمه العلمانيه الاوروبيه التي قامت
منذ اكثر من 200 سنه على مبدا فصل الدين
عن الدوله والمجتمع يتحالفون اليوم جميعا
لدعم عدوان دوله استعماريه تعرف نفسها على
اساس ديني ويحتفي قادتها باساطير تفوقها
العرقي اسئله اليوم التالي للحرب تحل اذا
على اسرائيل ومعها حلفائها الغربيون قبل
ان تضع الحرب او ها اما في غزه وفي عموم
ارض فلسطين فثم ذاكره تقول ان اليوم
التالي قد يستغرق سنوات او عقو من الزمن
يعجز فيها الغزاه عن كسر اراده اصحاب
البلاد ودليل هؤلاء الذين من فكوا ينزفون
دون ما توقف ان الايام التاليه
للنكبة احالات ليس من بينها
استسلامهم